[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the realm table of
dim lighting we're gonna be talking
about first kiss stories we've got
stories you've got stories and we've
actually got some of our mythical
entertainment crew members who also have
some stories yeah um so we're gonna go
down memory lane and it's gonna get a
little awkward well no it won't get
awkward will just be unpacking the
awkward so maybe that'll make it less
awkward there's some times that makes
people feel awkward when you talk about
awkward thanks I think you but it won't
in this case not and don't you worry
no no awkward analogies or anything but
you know what I wanted to make sure
before we talked about that that if you
Rhett have gone to any other doctor I
just wanted to make absolutely sure I
did not miss like I'm just starting to
develop a habit of like hey you know
tell me about your doctor visit like I
don't even know if you've been to the
doctor I'm just like wow how was your
doctor's visit today it is worth asking
though because I went to the doctor
today the bull's eye the whole target is
the bull's eye it's just a red it's just
a cool red thing on the wall it's not a
it's not a dart board at all I went the
decoration stopped throwing darts at it
this was a follow-up appointment I told
my whole my whole ENT my double ENT
visit you know I that was like weeks ago
and then what I didn't even tell anybody
about it was like yesterday I told well
I told you guys about it but I didn't
tell the air biscuit ears about this I
went to another ENT there was looking
closer there was far away cuz you didn't
like the answer you wanted you wanted
something worse you wanted somebody to
tell you some worse no we were but
that's not even the doctor that you went
to this morning it is it is same guy
okay so like six weeks oh we're talking
about by the time you hear this we will
be on our tour right when this comes out
well this when with this one with this
coming up oh this is ten - so we'll be
about what there would be a couple weeks
out from our tour but at the time that
so I went to the other ENT twice and he
was like you don't really have like you
know it's just he gave me all those the
prescriptions and stuff and actually I
really got better but then I started
realizing I don't think I'm getting
better fast enough to feel confident to
go on tour and like sing and talk and
you know and I was I know the songs that
we're gonna sing in the show and I'm
like starting to worry about my voice
being able to hold up and when I like
try to begin to practice them my voice
starts like not being able to do it so I
was like I'm gonna go to a guy who's
local because maybe it's something else
maybe it's allergies maybe it's maybe
there's something else going on I'm
gonna get a second opinion from somebody
who's closer and some weight and the guy
did the whole thing with the thing in
your throat video and again he confirmed
there's nothing there's no nodes or
anything specifically wrong it's just a
general irritation from something he was
like it's like sorry he's like it's
either allergies but it might be acid
reflux and I'm like acid reflux so it
gives me a prescription for basically
generic nexium whatever or something
that's like a what do they call it
protein pump something I don't know what
it is basically make sure stomach make
less acid so I'm like a week into taking
that just as a precaution but then he's
also like and you should come back for
an allergy test just to make sure that
it's not allergies in the meantime
basically he sees the writing on the
wall that this tall guy well I can I can
milk him for everything I'm a given this
drug I'm again I'm gonna give him this
test oh man we got a whole I got a whole
regimen what put you through and I've
also always want to bill you for it too
I've also always wondered like cuz you
know I've got all these skin
sensitivities and stuff and like
different foods it would just be fun to
know that you're allergic I would I want
to know like okay is it is there
anything definitive
that you can find so I wonder what was
it the tight where they put this stuff
all over your back yeah I'll get to that
one second in the meantime I continue to
get just for those of you who are unlike
link who were actually worried about me
even though he is gonna be singing with
me he's gonna be trying to harmonize
with me which is gonna be very difficult
if there is no voice comes right out of
it's difficult to harmonize with no one
my things get a little bit better every
single week but there's little setbacks
but I get a little bit better so I'm not
so I've lost my like overarching fear
that something really wrong is something
there could be something really wrong
but I've lost my fear that something
really wrong there's something really
wrong with me cuz I'm getting it's not
getting worse it's getting slowly better
and I think that the timing even if I
continue at this rate it's gonna be okay
but I was like I got this allergy test
scheduled I'm gonna go in for it that
was this morning so I go in there and
the woman who administers the test this
is what she does she does it for
multiple doctors okay and there was a
and actually I Instagram a picture of me
sort of shirtless just you know like his
shoulder I didn't want to give you I
didn't want to give you I wanted to keep
you want more just give you a list give
you a shoulder of me right there next to
all the little things all the vials so
basically the way this works is they
have concentrates of all these different
allergens and like it's like cockroach
dog cat like animals and then there's
yeah and then like molds like multiple
molds penicillin mold another kind of
mold and then different weeds and then
different all kinds of plants animals
environmental things and and what they'd
a bit on you two different things the
first test is she has it almost looks
like an ice tray and all these things
are stuck needles are soaking in this
concentrate but they're like six
together in one so she was like yes this
used to all be one at a time but now we
just take this thing and just press it
up against your back at all six of them
prick you at the same time
there's 30 of them oh so you may be 36
6x so then it's soaking in dog how do
you get first of all how do you get dog
concentrate
dogs use that's the main thing I was
thinking the whole time is how did they
concentrate a dog down to that I mean it
did they kill a dog for this it's a big
blender or do they just take like a
piece of the tail I don't know how they
got it I mean hopefully it was humane
but I have no way of knowing maybe it's
just the hair maybe they shave a dog and
then they just they put it in a blender
and then they see what's left
they squeegee a dog you bathe the dog
and you get bath water squeegee it okay
so I sew it but you don't get one needle
you get like six and I'm I'm on your
back first starts on your back okay and
how much surface area are all these
needles concentrated in is it like like
a thumbnail size or smaller no with each
six if they they all come that's six
right there Oh like an index card yeah
yeah little bit smaller than an index
card and they push an index card size
it's got six points on it oh wow and
they and it doesn't hurt I mean it's a
little prick but it doesn't hurt and she
also injects you with a hist straight
because you don't have you don't have
that much surface area on your back to
do six index card index cards do you
heck yeah I do
well you're a tall guy yes it's might
only have seven it's smaller five well
seven is more than six math major that
is true but they're still pretty small
well I'm not a math major just for the
radio that was being facetious
it was just a weird references something
I never was everything to be so major my
wife is a math major that's why I
married her she also did not know she
gives you a straight histamine shot
because everyone will react to a
histamine injection if he unless you've
taken antihistamines that's why you
can't take any antihistamines for a week
before the test that's a control group
so good to see you Calvin
and then she does that and she does the
six and she's like wait 15 minutes she's
like you're probably gonna start itching
or whatever and I was like well I'm
itching in like 1
place and then she comes back and she's
like well you really only rillette
reacting to the histamine and not even
reacting that much to it which is weird
because like as people pointed out on
the Instagram post like remember what
happened to me with the maple syrup on
the show yeah yeah it made like this red
pattern exactly where it was like a
raise and maple syrup was not one of the
things that was put into my body so so
then she says okay well sure chant now
I've got to confirm that with it like I
sit she caught it a subdermal something
but basically she then she came over on
this arm and she there was four
different levels of concentrations of
the same thing and based on the initial
test she does a confirmation test on
your arm it took an hour and 15 minutes
and then she goes through and she pricks
like she injects all the stuff into one
arm and you can like see the skin like
bubble up with me with the concentration
underneath there and then you wait
another 15 minutes to see if you react
to that and then long story short I
ended up having mild mild reaction she
said mild to moderate but I think it was
mild reactions to penicillin mold
another kind of mold dogs a mild
reaction to dogs
yeah and I know I've got the report in
the car
but isn't Barbara the type of dog that
you wouldn't be allergic to well no dogs
are truly hypoallergenic but some are
more hypo some some are less allergenic
than others but she was like how long
have you had the dog and I was like two
years and she was like well that's about
how long it takes for this for your for
you to develop an allergic reaction to
something but she was also like but it's
mild it's not like you've got to get rid
of the dog she was like these are the
things you need to do and she was like
you should get like a you should have
like a filter in your house and dust
mites - she was like how old are your
pillows and I felt guilty because we
made a whole freaking song about how you
supposed to replace your pillow like
every two year or two yeah every year
and I was like more than two years she
was like you should get a new pillow
every year get new pillows don't store
stuff under your bed don't store stuff
store stuff under your bed
causes people to not clean up under your
bed there's no vacuuming that happens I
think stay in the same place and dust
mites so anyway she thinks that it might
have something to do with that but it
was one of those things like you just no
definitive answers good news bad news
good news is it's not like something was
some crazy reaction bad news was well if
I did there was at least I'd know what
to do well I'm I'm sincerely sorry that
you're okay
just joking man but I'm not gonna have
to give away Barbara but I'm gonna have
to put her in a put her in a bubble
she'll like it in me a hurry I'd be in
the bubble well you could it's a much
bigger bubble for you all right guys
let's uh let's shift gears here a little
bit to promote some merch that we want
you to have here it is
we got some good mythical summer stuff
that let's be honest we don't want it
anymore we want you to have it
and it's because it's not summer anymore
so we're gonna give you a huge 35%
discount because here's the thing
summers coming again and when we're
selling this again next summer it's
gonna be full price and you're gonna
think back to this moment when you were
like I got it for 35% off and you're
like I don't need towels and tanks right
now I don't need towels and tanks
exactly I always buy shorts now my
shorts now I always I always buy jackets
in the summer in at the beginning of the
summer right or at that like halfway
through spring your clearance man I get
the I'm a clearance man call me Clarence
um Clarence Neal Clarence Carter
Clarence Carter that's what they call me
so here get this stuff you're not gonna
regret it it's like an investment in
your summer yeah and it's gonna pay
dividends of looking awesome get those
arms toned now so you can bust them out
in the good mythical tank top with the
towel and you can use a beach towel
year-round you can what no you don't dry
it'll dry just as well right off with it
that's a deal on just as a towel it is a
killer deal yeah it could be a bath
towel mythical dot store mythical dot
store good to know now on with the
biscuit
[Music]
my first girlfriend was Leslie but I did
not kiss her my first girlfriend was
Leslie you don't say um a little bit
later the neck in the next year
I'm seventh grade and I did not kiss her
cuz you dated in sixth grade but hey
neither one of us kissed her I got so
close man you got close oh yes I got
close like you had you attempted you did
like a flyby room I was at the dance and
I had a Buies Creek Elementary School
cafeteria that's where we did the dance
and I was sitting there up against the
wall like there were chairs up against
the wall sitting next to Leslie and then
right next to me another couple who was
the other couple Leslie's best friend
amber and who was she dating at the time
they did in for a long time I don't
remember
Matt McKinney McKinney
yes Matt McKinney yeah they had a good
thing going you down but we were sitting
there and I was okay I had my and I
never kissed a girl I would have my arm
around her and then I had my other hand
interlocked with her hand not awkward at
all just like so into this moment so you
were you had her like incarcerated like
she couldn't run away right and but the
funny thing is is I found out later that
your arms are so long and gangly she
what she wanted me and I wish I had have
known this she wanted me to kiss her but
I didn't know I just didn't know and I
was so nervous and I remember like
sitting like we danced you know and then
I'm and I'm in my position and I'm
Justin everything I don't know what to
do how do you start I just I seen it on
television but I just I just got to do
that's got to commit and the next thing
I know my dad is there
you like taps me on the head on the head
that was your moment that's when you
should have kissed he's like come on boy
time to go home and you said that going
in for the kiss right then no no it's
like I think your dad might have been
like subtly trying to push your head
into her face they didn't feel that way
you know like yeah it was more of a you
were subject to me and we're out of here
yeah yeah I know what you're up to I
don't remember getting anywhere near
that close to kissing Leslie at any sort
of engagement because I was so clueless
and still am in a lot of ways my second
girlfriend was amber oh she was my
second girlfriend as well and she was my
first kiss oh she was my first kiss this
is all true so you dated Leslie in sixth
grade I dated Leslie and beginning of
seventh grade and then I skipped right
over once Leslie dumped me because I was
so clueless man what's that still cousin
I've already umber in seventh grade I've
always remembered that and then you
dated amber I was a six or eight and you
had her in you doubled up in seventh
grade yeah big year for me I bookended
you with amber and Leslie and then you
had the amber and Leslie year seventh
grade well I think we should bookend
this conversation with each of our first
kiss Oh stories with the same girl amber
and see who did a better job yeah yeah
we can make it a competition I'm I'm
sure we already did so we could talk
about that but but before we do I do
want to read some mythical beast
accounts of first kisses because we did
ask you guys to tell us about your first
kiss stories thank you for all who did
that we asked for some for some honest
yet funny ones Kimberly said I was 16 at
the time we were watching bulletproof
monk you seen that movie no does it
sound like a kissing
no it doesn't sound like a make-out
movie and my boyfriend of six months
decided that this was the best time to
try so yeah she kind of admits it like
he's kind of ballin headed
he missed twice once because my head was
in the wrong direction I was watching
the movie so he like tried to give her a
kiss but it ended up like pecking the
side of her head or something yeah right
it happens and the second because our
glass is smashed into each other hmm
yeah that's an added source of anxiety
I mean first kiss like you're you're
concerned about what's gonna happen
there's some so many logistics I mean
the first time I tried to water-ski it
was not pretty
what what do you mean what waterskiing
and kissing are very similar explain
please
like there's a lot of forces involved
and you're bound to get wet like
waterskiing is waterskiing I hadn't
thought of this ahead of time but I
really think it's very very shut up
that was funny man it sounded like a
setup and a punch line it was it was
funny it was funny well I actually
laughed yeah I did laugh I made up a
joke on the spot but I legitimately was
thinking about that all the technical
things that have to come together at
once in order to like get up on your
skis while being pulled behind a boat on
a body of water and then maintaining
some sort of equilibrium so that you can
have fun yay it's just like first kiss
well I could say for someone who I am a
person who has both a water-skied and
kiss and I could say kissing is a lot
easier than waterskiing it comes a whole
lot more naturally speak for yourself
Kimberly says he did finally get there
and it was pretty good yeah you got a
make and and I think she means a third
attempt in that same
bulletproof monk viewing session you got
to make this is when echolocation comes
into play you got to make some kind of
visual you have to have some sort of
audio cue that you're coming in
something I don't know what everybody
has a different sound like sonar yeah
you can yeah
there's got to be an indication it could
be something more subtle like just a
slight rustle of the clothing or
something like that just to let me wait
you got to get that the the person's
head turned your way because that's also
how you find out if they're into it
right
you can't just be see somebody watching
a movie and just pounce on them like
that
no there needs to be informed consent
exactly yeah yeah got it and that is at
least the person's head is turned
towards you so they have they have the
ability to accept or reject as you move
closer this ended well we married a few
moments later no you a few years after
high school and we'll be celebrating six
years there's November
congratulations Kimberly well PS we
still watch bulletproof monk together
oh nothing gives me going like that
bulletproof monk baby I don't even have
any idea what you put on the bulletproof
monk I think it's an action flick that
has kung-fu overtones okay let me read a
few more just to just totally wet our
palates to wet the skis so to speak to
lick the lips I'm going in for another
one okay hold on to your ropes I could
tell by the way that that sound bounced
back into my ears it was bouncing off of
fleshy lips yeah I mean I'm just making
sure we're an open mouth I'm carrying
that one didn't bounce back the skiing
analogy further make sure you got your
gas in your tank I don't know I'm just
trying to help you up you can you can
rip your arm off your body if the person
driving the boat it involves two people
to see it's not just you you it's a
dance with the with the person driving
the boat you see yeah sometimes there's
somebody else in the boat this analogy
is unsinkable yeah Chloe said my first
kiss was at the park in my hair flew in
my face and then an elderly woman
clapped and I tripped on my shoes right
after I think it just goes to show you
that somebody clams and an elderly woman
clap you know you got going on and I
don't know if she clapped like applause
or if it was like she was distracted by
an elderly woman just happening like
slap her hands together
it sounds like applause in the context
well that's a good sign sometimes if
elderly people are clapping that's a
good first kid elderly people love to
clap for skiers that's one thing I've
noticed anytime I've gotten gotten it up
we've gotten Mesquite stood out while
skiing Unsinkable but you know there's
you're a bundle of nerves because
there's so many things that can go wrong
I've only read two of these and there's
been seven things that have gone wrong
just the two stories Danny nine he said
he and I were in the middle of our first
proper kiss and a bird pooped on his
head slash face and some of the poop got
into my mouth okay now I don't have a
tough time believing this one now eight
well it can't happen somewhere on earth
yeah a bird is pooping over people
having a first look what are the chances
that we asked that question and one of
the mythical beasts actually had it
happen to him
Danny 90 Rhett is calling you a liar I
mean I don't know it could have happened
and if we can talk about it like oh
that's crazy I can't believe that
happening so gross but I also have
trouble believing it
try to say that I could be wrong I
wasn't there I'm not a bird rat stranger
things have happened on skis yeah think
about I'm sure someone has been crapped
on while skiing and it probably was no
big deal cuz you just know all in the
water
well no cuz your mouths open a little
and it gets in there you got I'm sure
I've never kept my mouth open while
skiing
well you don't ski a lot sometimes
sometimes your mouth gates open when
you're skiing well when you give a
signal to the boat maybe I'm Kylie boat
sickness I will bet that birds have
pooped multiple birds have pooped into
multiple into the same mouth while
skiing and so I believe that Danny 90 is
telling the truth why wasn't skiing what
he wasn't skiing who was she wasn't his
king Danny Knight that was a first kiss
yeah if she was skiing I believe it you
lost me Mandy was 16 after the date
I told my mom that I thought I got a
kiss but I wasn't sure the actions were
there but I wasn't sure if we make
contact or not really well you don't
believe her either that level of
unsurpassed for mythical beast
contributions if you're gonna call what
roll on it I don't know if it's just a
number the stories that you're choosing
but I'm also a little bit surprised at
the ages that's two sixteen year olds in
a row like in my book that's I mean that
seems late I'm not trying I'm not
judging anybody I'm just saying that
like I if anything my first kiss was in
the early 90s and I and I was 14 at the
time and I felt late amongst my friends
well I beat have people's things are
slowing down I mean you've got something
to be hopeful about I hope so they're
starting in 16 these days so she got a
ghost kiss again it's like who knew you
could fear that now that's another thing
to fear phantom kiss Phantom ghost kiss
all right and then this one
Marissa stole it was winter and we were
sitting on my front steps
there wasn't any snow but it was frosty
we had talked about how fishy already
[Laughter]
guys I do I believe I'm not gonna it
wasn't any snow but it was frosty we had
talked about it beforehand because he
had to talk himself up to it and
apparently talked her up to it as well
it was cold enough that oh gosh his nose
was doing that thing with the clear
liquid that's kind of snot but more
watery that's worse am I reading this
when he kissed me his first kiss ever
his nose drip fell straight onto my lips
and and I couldn't brush it away until
he left to walk home I just told him it
had her up in my mouth I just told him
this after three years of being together
and he's
he's mortified like he didn't know for
three years they say oh they were known
I don't know she didn't say but not only
does um he now know but now we all know
Marissa yeah
Marissa told everybody I almost said her
last name but I'm a buddy role so okay
we we primed the pump I believe that one
now you believe that last one yeah yeah
it had a ring of truthfulness yeah the
most false part was the frosty frosty
frosty but not snowing you get that nose
drip you don't know it it's so cold
outside you don't know that it's there
you're going in for the kiss I'm glad
that I'm over that hump well way over it
let me tell you brother lots of kissing
with my wife you know okay you don't
have to reassure us it's like Oh big boy
Wow
he's been kissing big boys they made for
seven big boy big boy well she didn't
know okay but what about your first man
because you need to talk about amber and
then I'll talk about everything it was
somebody's birthday party and they were
it was it wasn't hampers but it was in
Lillington I don't know it wasn't that
place well yeah it was at the Lillington
Puritan virgin like a ruin building like
doors in building it's like I'm you
defiled by Puritan building like one of
those chamber commerce e / it's where we
your grandma wasn't ruin but it was like
a Rotary Club your grandmother
invited us back to perform songs for her
her senior citizen citizens Club at that
place like it was like five years ago
well that's funny he was right before we
left to come to California so it's right
like six or seven years ago but yeah we
say show up and sing about showing up
all of her retired old folk friends and
the first thing our opener was hey my
first kiss was here yeah
allow me to demonstrate any volunteers
like I jump at any chance to make out
with an elderly woman yeah that lady I
got a lot of pent-up it's like ferocious
okay I only kissed my wife yeah except
for that lady show that lady at that
demonstration at one time I was reaching
it it was theatrical you know it was
just prove a point it's like the actors
the actors kissing all the time and it
doesn't count right that's what it was
when you kissed that old lady the
roaring Club I'm doing this as an actor
to prove a point
there was a proudly on display just to
the left of this place was a caboose no
caboose yeah now it would have been an
epic makeout story if we had kissed in
the caboose but no we were in like you
walk in the front door and it's a big
rectangular room with nothing but like
metal folding chairs that wrestlers used
to beat each other with without the rest
and and elderly people sit on for like
group meetings yeah but for some reason
it was this middle-school birthday party
there I think it was like Betsy's party
because she was from Lillington don't
don't remember but I was going with
amber for a while
I'd even successfully talked to her on
the phone a while yep so I was like
really on a roll I mean that's what we
called at the time was going with and
nobody's dancing nobody dances this
thing and the lights are up and there
are adults they're too bright and I'm
like there are adults here hey no wait a
minute Sheriff I'm gonna kiss my
girlfriend there is no way I am way too
timid for that to have to get up on your
skis when there's that much light and
those many people are right
so I'm sitting next to her I don't have
my arm around her much less my other
hand intermingled with her fingers like
should have talked I didn't have her
lock down a whole year earlier I was
doing that so it was me then amber then
Anna and then Michael
Oh Michael and Anna Michael and Anna
were yep it was you know was my there's
like 20 people in our class so everybody
dated everybody and you ended up dating
the same girls in the same order who's
like musical chairs right yeah just you
know everybody politely waited their
turn right and then someone was
awkwardly standing there
alone yeah until the music played again
because no one got eliminated
right yeah we didn't do that and then I
just I'm trying to remember the details
dang it
but amber she had ideas she was a she
was a girl with ideas I know she had an
older sister okay had advised her a
little bit and so she knew about kissing
the only reason I dated her is because
she she basically said will you go with
me and then but in this instance I think
she told and I really wanted to but I
would never stood timid to ask her and
she didn't go in for the kiss it wasn't
that simple what happened was she was
murmuring with Anna and then all of a
sudden I think Michael kind of got in on
the conversation and then they were
murmuring in leaning forward and then
Michael leans back behind and amber and
like motions me and said then I'm like
leaning over and he's like man so it's
like amber told Anna told Michael told
me yeah came all the way around the horn
kiss her man and then there was an
implication I don't think he said it out
loud but there was an implication in our
time it Oh
Michael was a timer Michael was yeah man
oh I'll talk about Michael a little bit
when I get in my story Michael was a
sage and then amber and Anna stop
talking and Michael and Anna started
making out that's all you need I see if
Matt Namur had had done that for me and
Lesley I wouldn't be here today cuz you
know you make certain decisions and then
everything gets goes I mean it's gonna
mean this is what happens that's how the
universe works man so I'm glad I didn't
dude I had to I'm glad I'm here I looked
across the row at an building and like
everybody was watching and waiting yeah
yeah and it was not you know me I at a
certain point I'm a performer man right
it comes out like I got that dream
get up on the skis yep one chance
me down and I had to she was on my right
side I had to lean over and go across on
leaning left which I would later learn
is not my best side right like once I
started figuring this out I would always
be on the right side of my girlfriend so
I could go and go over and lean to the
right I'm much better at the right yeah
that's all the way your hair parts yeah
exactly right that's how you know you
look like a sail look at the crown of
your head right you got a rudder and a
sail and you're getting the sailboat I
mean we're still on the water you get on
the sailboat
you've got the sail going the wrong way
starboard whatever side that is and you
want to go the other way whatever that's
called you know but you're still skiing
behind it which I'm sure it's possible
yeah with one of those in the like a
clipper know one of those that goes
really fast and what do they call that
the America's Cup you can ski behind
water-ski
yeah rip your arm right off of your body
I leaned in to the left and starboard it
was I'm certain I was not her first kids
at the front of the back of the boat
what is left I don't aft port EFT I
don't know can I tell my story I just
like I had a good ski analogy now you're
all excited because it's sailing like
you're legitimately wanting to make this
about sailing I'm in the middle of my
story I'll learn the terms I'm leaning
to the left and I'm certain this was not
Amber's first kiss because she took
charge and I'm grateful for it yeah um
it wasn't bad at all I actually felt
like I was doing okay and how long I've
seemed well Michael reported to me later
that it was do you remember the number
because I think it's either 12 or 14
seconds I don't I don't remember your
number I know my number shorter than
that Wow twelve fourteen I believe so
I'm so bad with math though well you
don't have to add anything it could have
been 1.2 or 1.4 seconds to know
no it was you misplaced a dozen what
once I was once I initiated she took
over and then I was just along for the
ride your yeah I just held on to the
Rope baby yeah you hold on and keep your
skis pointing in the right direction now
you're gonna kid somewhere and yeah and
go to 14 that seems about right and then
when we get when we parted ways one
second for every year of age everybody
was looking there was not applause which
made it off Barone's
I I was I didn't want to look I I did
not look for chaperones to make eye
contact cuz that was the last thing I
wanted and I broke the seal
and I was never the same you didn't kiss
her again though did you you didn't date
her for very long I don't remember why
you guys broke up you know what I don't
know I really don't know if if I if I
had a second go at it I think that was
it from whatever I think that goes in it
because even though we were literally we
were five miles maybe three miles apart
Buies Creek in Lillington for some
reason when summer came it was like well
I'll never see you again
right I think you guys broke up you hit
the summer wall and so and then he
didn't reestablish it in the next year
because I did right yeah but I was
dating Anna at the time and I kissed her
a lot a lot I remember that at the
parties were that were arranged for that
type of thing to happen right makeout
parties okay but you know what not only
do you mythical beasts have stories
about first kisses not only do the two
of us have stories about first kisses
but some of our mythical entertainment
employees also have some very
interesting stories including Ellie
welcome Ellie to the show Ellie you take
i'm graciously giving you my spot do you
want to talk into my microphone hello
check-check don't smell it just talk
into it don't breathe in breathe out
when we did our Six Flags outing like we
were in different groups of people and
we happen to be in the same group
we were we were it was a group of us in
line is somehow we were talking about
we started talking my first kiss story
so I heard a little bit of this but I
think that's part of what gave me the
idea to for us to talk about this under
near biscuit because I I enjoyed your
insights producing on my time oh you
were on the clock it was a team-building
exercise you were not on vacation it
just felt like it that's how fun it is
to be on the message you got paid to
ride roller coasters that's true yeah
we're actually gonna take a vacation day
from you okay so what's your story
okay well it's funny cuz it has there's
some interesting parallels but my first
kiss was in middle school 7th grade to
be exact and I was dating this guy named
Steve well Steve and my best friend was
also dating a guy named Steve who called
him Steve one and Steve - who Steve and
the way that things worked at my middle
school was like like you're talking
about how everyone in the retirement
home was watching you kiss we would go
we would be like walking home from
school and whoever you've been paired up
with whoever you've coupled up with
which like looking back on it seemed
arbitrary like it just seemed like
someone was like I like you and your
friend would be like yeah you should
like I'm back and I'd be like okay I
told you to like him back yeah it's like
your friends have it's like very
democratic is that good so you didn't
want to be with Steve no no I did it's
like I developed a crush retro actively
like when you start dating them it's not
like you're dating because you have this
instant spark you know cuz you don't
even know what a spark is that was my
experience of it and you would walk home
from school and like the groups of kids
would like circle around who was coupled
up and like basically like encouraged us
to like make steps along the like dating
process so like Steve and I hadn't even
held a hand
when we first started dating we like
barely looked at each other in the eye
you know so we would walk home and like
the first step was they like all circle
around us and they were like you guys
should hug circle it's like a tribal
initiation or something everyone would
watch and then we would be like okay and
then we'd like step forward and then
like pause and then like hug nothing's
been more romantic
there you go from there yeah well it was
like electric yeah oh wow no I remember
being like oh my god this is happening
so that's how my first like boyfriend
hug happened the old boyfriend hug that
comes first
yeah yeah the boyfriend hug comes first
and so my friend you know let's come
Steve - okay they they would circle
around the both of us maybe like you do
it and then you do it so I I hugged
Steve one and she hugs Steve - the
Steve's rug chained the Steve's really
it worked out well for them Steve yeah I
don't even know if they were friends
before this they just like the guy thing
Steve's now I've seen and I believe I've
also done it I've seen two people skiing
behind one boat at watching so again my
analogy still hope I've seen the whole
pyramid I love I love the water-ski
analogy you were throwing shade at it
but like the overwhelming power of like
being pulled up that's the point what
the power of the engine is your own
hormones oh yeah right wrong unfiltered
yeah okay so so - so we we did the hug
in a circle on the walk home but like
kissing that's crazy like that's a whole
other step that oh yeah that's that's
just intense so we wouldn't your
language whole yeah we would have these
like hangouts alright um yeah let your
language is most important whole
[Laughter]
well so so the like the cool girls in
middle school would who had like the
nice houses with the fancy basements
would organized like hangouts parties
where the whole goal was to kiss on the
mouth yeah yeah basements are trouble
in middle school a huge trouble but then
like in retrospect it's not trouble
because the parents know what's
happening and they're like oh as long as
you're in the house I know you're up to
Josh and Joey
the twins had a baseball database man
they had a base they were tomorrow our
basement parties happen in twins
basement yeah where's Lisa cuz when
you're like we have got to sequester
this Double Trouble somewhere
underground they keep one of the twins
in the basement do you want to deal with
one at a time that's the basement for
when quarantine so you you knew Steve
was going down to the basement no like
like a group of six couples like so six
couples 12 children got invited to the I
guess I shouldn't say that last name but
to one of the twins basement and like
there were like chips there was music
playing the whole like seeing like a
party but all anyone wanted to do was
kiss and I was so nervous cuz like I I I
didn't have an older sister like amber I
had an older brother and he would just
be like don't talk to me I'd rather not
when you're growing up not the same and
so I would just read like Cosmo or 17
and they go way beyond what you're ready
for like I had just hugged in a circle
and they're talking about like 69 ways
to like blow his mind
etc so I was just like I don't know what
to expect I'm super stressed out so we
made a game it was basically like seven
minutes in heaven or spin the bottle but
like they spun it
it was so Arbor
because they were just spinning it so
that people landed on the respective
boyfriend or girlfriend obviously yeah
and so they like point the bottle yeah
so they did it was it a bottle it was a
bottle it was a spray bottle I remember
vividly sprite mmm not a sponsor right
not as you're right I mean all night no
okay all right I just lost another
potential sponsor well you know our
language holes will drink sprite so
great for your language hole um well so
so I was I was superintending on other
couples and they would go into different
corners of the basement to kiss everyone
would turn like like we were like
promising that we wouldn't look but we
would all want yeah and I you just hear
slurping sounds you know like mouth
sounds yeah I know the worst and and it
finally got down to me and Carly and our
Steve's and they were just like they
were like oh like we were all gonna go
to a movie or something I think like
Shark Tale 3d or something stupid like
that
hey uh uh bring Shark Tale 3d in it is
and and they were like you guys should
go at the same time yeah you're both
Steve yeah I mean but obviously and so
they were like you guys go and we both
went into different like I was on I was
like underneath the stairwell and she
was like by this bookcase and we like I
see Carmi start to kiss her Steve and me
and my Steve are just like uh like like
panicking totally like like ruining the
moment like we were just supposed to get
into it and we didn't do it that's the
whole point of the whole party and I
wish you miss that a mission that I'm
gonna show a little window the boats got
a circle around clip me right yeah well
so so the boats are bobbing hold your
ski up
run away so that other boats don't come
through and hit you there true while
your boat is circling around to give you
your rope again in this metaphor my skis
had blown all the way over the other
side of the lake and so I just
remembered from magazines like Cosmo and
17 they were like be confident like like
so I grabbed his face and I'm just like
brought it to my face and then we were
just face to face and then I just went
did you say no no I just was trying to
avoid making actual stupid kissing how
did Steve respond um well I didn't know
that there was a tongue element like I
never knew that was a thing they don't
talk about that they don't talk about
I'm sure they do but I like didn't
realise I guess I was just I was a child
and so I just thought it was this like a
catfish in the skiing analogy yeah
unexpected Kathy no but like like a fish
though I just thought kissing was this
yeah like a duck or a fish I just
thought it was like Papa and there's a
whole other part there's a whole I
didn't know about it and so I go and he
thought he thought you rheticus you
don't want face grabbing I know I
grabbed his face I should have been
ready and all I knew is like it is
foreign object was in my mouth and I
thought it was a giant wad of gum
honestly I thought it was a giant wad of
like sour guns
oh it's our he probably had eaten sour
gum earlier we were children we were
having candy all the time and like it
was ready it was like it was like your
whole mouth puckered yeah yeah no but I
was like what is that like I didn't know
what it was it tasted sour tasted like
oh it just it just seemed like a wad of
gum I couldn't even figure it out and I
had no like mental capacity to like use
my tongue to figure it out I was just
like frozen I'm sure it was just like a
dead slug visually it'll just make its
way completely into my mouth
I'll start chewing but yeah
ever happen I was genuinely confused and
I never really got an answer but but we
apparently made out longer than everyone
else probably because I was spending the
whole time trying to figure out what was
happening and everyone everyone like
applauded for us oh you got actual
applause I got applause Wow for both of
did an elderly woman clap like all of a
sudden yeah the twins mom came down I
was like nice hour no but that was my
first kiss with that Steve and he broke
up with me on a walk home later and and
all right no it was like a couple weeks
later like like we went on to a kiss I
think maybe one more time we saw like a
different movie in a theater and I got
another unexpected tongue and I didn't
know so weird but was there a debrief
involved after the first one like I
never talked with him I never talked to
Amber about how was that because I could
use some pointers well that would have
been nice I wish like communication is
everything and I think like it's so
funny to think back on it because in
seventh grade of course no one knows
what they're doing but in seventh grade
we were still trying to pretend like
yeah I've done this before you know as I
flip my sweater thing back like hair
there's there was no debrief
there's no debrief like I think I wanted
him to think that I knew what I was
doing I didn't ask him if he had gum in
his mouth you know yeah I still wonder
about that cuz I remember the texture
and it is haunting maybe he's got a gum
tone maybe some people have it well he
broke up with me on ceremoniously there
were all these rumors that he went to
Kay Jewelers with his mom to get me like
a present for Christmas like ever I
don't even know how the rumor started
but instead he broke up with me on the
walk home and it was frosty and the
tears froze on my face
I remember just yelling I like like and
I had like a gaggle of girls around me
like come comforting me and he was
walking like 20 feet behind me Wow it
was awful
but I was redeemed because in eighth
grade he made out with my friend Molly
cuz I also I totally get the like mixing
and matching because there's not that
many people you just feel like yeah do
your thing so my friend Molly gonna take
made out with him in the exercise room
of the other twins basement in eighth
grade crazy and he was so aggressive
with his tongue she nicknamed him Tunnel
puncher and the nickname tongue puncher
spread throughout the entire school and
in the high school and I've never been
more vindicated oh my goodness yeah yeah
the other Steve ended up stealing a car
and tongue buncher's mine steers tend to
be easily I wonder if the nickname
followed him to jail Steve one tongue
puncher Wow well you know what um how
has it impacted you for the rest of your
life I mean are you are you alright now
yeah well I think we didn't get broken
up with for the first time it's like I
don't think you feel emotions as
strongly as you do when you feel them
the first time so yeah like I think I've
always been very confident so it was my
first experience of someone being like
no and that's why I was like why so you
did it definitely affected me but I mean
I've had so many boyfriends you've
recovered well yeah I'm thriving Billy
thank you for sharing your story wow
yeah that was great
I'll remember that one better than I
remembered my own story okay movies got
more stories we got more mythical
stories let's bring in Becca Becca
welcome to Becca you've been waiting in
the wings I don't know does it is it
better to wait in the wings cuz Rhett
was like why don't know if they want to
wait outside is it it's better to sit
here and be a part of this it was
nice to be a part of this whole
experience of everybody just to hear
your stories well link your story hen
yeah your head your head and of course
hearing Ellie's story I think it's
always fun to hear other girls first
kiss stories of sort of what their
experiences were at this deeply
tumultuous sort of absolutely terrible
period of life called being a teen girl
and it's like it's so perfectly awkward
it's so perfectly terrible in every way
and there's so many variables mm-hmm
you know it's kind of like yeah you know
what you thinking I've heard it's a bit
like skiing tell us your story I've -
there's gonna be a two-for-one special
here guys oh yeah for for those of you
watching who are not aware of this I am
a lesbian yes that is a thing
so bison thing I don't know whoa whoa
whoa whoa what did you know what great I
went back to you we're going back to my
first kiss ever
this is ninth grade I'm gonna set the
scene for you it's ninth grade
this is the fall early winter of 2013 13
almost 14 I've just come off of a really
riveting summer wherein I played at
least eight to ten hours a day of final
fantasy xi an MMORPG is there much
making out in that there was absolutely
no making out in that no I played as a
cat girl I was a Red Mage I did a lot of
magic well for making out it prepares
you not at all for making out so how is
there any fantasy much less a final one
yeah you know and that was 11 they're
onto like 15 now it's it's never final
lots and lots of that alone in my room
with my guild mates who ranged from
friends of mine who I knew in real life
IRL as you would and like a bunch of
guys in the military who had this may
have been the height of
Steve's he's just a bunch of Steve's
whole bunch of Steve interesting overlap
there's lots to both question Steve yeah
whole bunch of Steve's um and that's all
tell us that the first kiss you ever had
was digital no okay no no no this is
setting a stage for who Becca was when
she had her first cast okay I watched a
lot of anime that summer and I dyed my
hair jet jet black well to cosplay as an
anime character to an anime convention
that summer so the stage has been set as
to what kind of kid Becca was going into
ninth grade and early in ninth grade I I
was in the band I played flute and this
boy named Andy who played trumpet oh
valves on a trumpet only three valves on
the trumpet whole lotta body whole lot
of buttons oh yeah trumpet players tend
to be they're saucy a little they like
to draw attention there there were more
debonair there yeah they get bored with
only three valves then you gotta gotta
find other things to do all three of us
have hair that I would assume any ninth
grade trumpet player would have or try
to have but they're in ninth grade they
don't know how to take care of himself
yet so I was just real bad
he took her shine to me I took a shine
to him and it just sort of became this
place where we had this this fun banter
we were in band we had homeroom together
and it's like two boats on each side of
the lake just head straight for ya this
is this is one of the real Trixie fancy
moves and waterskiing the two boats and
then you trade it all well that's how
flutes and trumpets do yeah
but eventually at some point he he asked
me out and I mean asking me out was we
had a lunch date together at school oh
that's bold that's bold because
everybody is watching and then only do
that I mean definitely but he had an
older brother he was gonna advice from
an older brother he knew what he was
doing no no no the one kid who played
bassoon in our band had no chance at all
so you're like yeah something like that
what oh this wasn't when the kiss was
but we started dating I'm like I had I
had myself my first little boyfriend his
name was Andy Andy and Becca a B it
worked out trumpets flutes all that
stuff come the Winter Formal
oh this is the first kiss we're at the
Winter Formal together it's a dance
there's punch there's dresses there's a
lot of those fake snowflakes that you
buy everywhere a whole lot of those yeah
flocking the flocked tree yeah those
ones a lot of those the dance ends
uneventful dance I remember very little
of it he takes me home like a proper
gentleman to make my non-existent curfew
because my parents really didn't care
what I did because I was such a big
freaking nerd that they knew I wasn't
gonna try anything he drove his own car
no he did not his his mom picked us up
and dropped us off okay but she was like
a cool mom so it was okay and it was an
SUV too so we could sit in the way way
back and feel like we were getting
chauffeured no at my front door like
every just team like a freaking movie
this was an episode of Dawson's Creek
the tail end of like whatever you
thought was actually gonna happen on
Clarissa explains it all it never did
you know this was just a teen girl
fantasy I'm right there with a parents
were in the car his mom was mom was in
the car and he walks you to you he
walked me to my front door I unlocked
the door ever actually happened where
the headlights like blazing no she was
like she you couldn't see my front door
from my driveway so like we had a little
bit of privacy it was it was kind of a
nice moment Oh such a nice moment I was
wearing a red dress and I only remember
that because I spent most of this time
prior to the kiss looking at my feet
because I had no idea what was going on
I I'm the oldest child in my family I
have some older cousins like I said a
lot of anime a lot of online video games
nobody was preparing 13 year old Becca
for a first kiss my mom had pretty much
already given up at that point you
weren't thinking that it was about to
happen
I was because everybody was like
expecting that because we were dating he
was ostensibly my boyfriend I wore his
big weird army jacket all the time at
school that smelled awful but you know
that's that was the sign we were
instead II uh and we just kind of stood
there I'd unlocked my door and turned
around and I was looking at my feet a
lot and we weren't really saying
anything and I wasn't trying to leave
and he wasn't trying to leave and
neither of us were trying to leave but
also not trying to initiate anything and
then finally he kind of took my hand
that had the corsage on it cuz he had
gotten me a corsage
Klaatu young man and I kind of looked at
him and he looked at me and it just sort
of was like I guess we're gonna kiss now
um and her face is sort of came together
and just kind of touched and I didn't
wear glasses then I had contacts so we
just kind of like smash just kind of put
our faces on each other's faces and then
sort of just kind of there was like
weird just mouth grumblings against one
another
oh gosh he smelled exactly like a dry
erase board eraser a vivid scent memory
of that of knowing it smelled like
erasers knowing I had no idea what I was
doing you know why because I do homeboy
was practicing on the eraser I mean
there was no ink on his face he had done
a good job cleaning it off but he
smelled just like that
it's soft soft lips stuffed animals
oh my teddy bear got it your dog that
tell me I don't know I practice on
anything a lot of Naruto so what
happened after this it we just sort of
smushed faces there was no tongue I also
was not aware of the back of tongue with
something you could use he was not
either his older brother had not gotten
that far in prepping him but he wants to
lick a dry erase marker no I erase rah
we separated and it was kind of like
okay bye and I immediately what my
husband closed the door and went
upstairs and got on find a fantasy xi
where my friends who had also been at
the dance where are we on
and then in in our guild chat we were
all like seriously furious typing
furious typing with the bagging no I was
like I kissed Andy it was weird oh my
god and they were like so at that moment
you like it was like you're smooching
face and you're smelling dry eraser and
you're like I like girls that was
shortly after I'm not gonna lie it's
like that was a pivotal moment it was a
pretty pivotal moment in that I did not
get I did not get why moment kissing I
did not get the hype behind kissing
following that kiss I kissed this guy I
went upstairs I played Final Fantasy 11
for the rest of the night with Michael
mates and I had never given it a second
thought
Andy and I unn ceremony broke up like a
month later right good no more kissing
no more kissing
we never kissed again I never felt the
need or want to ever kiss him again I
did not understand what kissing was all
cracked up to be high school went on
there were some other kisses they were
unceremonious during this period of time
I was like no I don't get the kissing
right College comes I'm a absolute
closet basket case for college there was
absolutely very little kissing happening
in college I was just like oh no nobody
can know no kissing but then I'd go to
coop parties and I'd do the college kid
thing where I would consume a lot of
alcoholic beverages and then I would be
like woo I don't care I'm gonna kiss
everybody and then I would just kiss a
lot of people didn't matter that because
I could then hide my own shame in my in
my being gay
under the fact that everybody was drunk
and kissing each other because you know
that's how it does um and then my my
senior year of college was my first real
certifiable stamp it on the paper get it
notarized kiss with a lady that I can
recall
was not just because I was very drunk
and everybody was doing it first
meaningful first meaningful kiss yeah it
was also at a party so I know this ups
not good
I the set up is not great but it was the
last part of the year for a student
group I was involved in in college
called the university California rally
committee I was graduating I'd been in
the group for four years no we were like
the spirit organization on campus we uh
we we waved big old flags at the
football games any waters there's no
water skiing involved I did I did I did
win surf in high school I learned how to
windsurf and I had a scene like kissing
not not only okay so it was the last are
there big blowout party at the end of
the year I'm a graduating senior
everything's all good I'm like yeah
graduating college I have no idea what I
want to do with my life but I'm
graduating from college yeah this is
great
and I am approached in the kitchen by
another member of this group who were
you I was yeah yeah I came out in
college and I was still just like in my
head a complete closet case and not
actually pursuing that but it was
definitely very very out okay I'm very
like hey guys look at me with my bad
zooey deschanel style blunt bang haircut
y'all knew me when I had that one it
wasn't good I might look like a member
of a case and the new girl however I am
very gay please tell everybody I am
desperate I would like to kiss anyone at
this point and it was just not happening
because once it ever came to like my
friend I was like oh no panic the things
yeah I was I was cornered basically in
the kitchen while refilling my my adult
beverage at this party and I turn around
and it's a girl who is also in the rally
committee she is a junior year behind me
blonde real cute
known her for a couple years never had
an inkling at all in my head that she
was even remotely on the spectrum of
anything but a hundred percent straight
and she's like hey I was like oh hi
not thinking that this is where this is
going and she's like immediate word
vomit just word vomit completely just
like you're really cute I think you're
really cute I think I have a crush on
you but I'm crushing you for a while
you're graduating I don't know what
you're doing after college I don't know
if you're moving you get to like a
thousand miles in however it's basically
her confessing that she had a crush on
me and me being like that's cool my
language whole was AG at just just jaw
on the floor like you had just put so
many words back inside and no words came
out of my mouth whole my language whole
many words came out of her language and
I was like that's really great and she
was like okay and left oh she left she
walked away from me a couple hours later
after several more adult beverages okay
she cores me in the kitchen again and
this time I'm making a drink and she
taps me on the shoulder and I turn
around and she pushes me up against a
fridge and shoves her tongue down my
throat he was a trumpet player too also
the flute player oh really
also a flute player no no I'm just more
woodwinds and I don't that brass up in
here I'm a woodwind only kind of girl
these days you know alright she shoved
her tongue down my throat and we started
furiously making out against this
refrigerator
you know much to the raucous cheers of
acute sound girl everyone we know it was
not a good kiss but it was a meaningful
cast it hurt no it was more shocking and
surprising a gum tone no gum time just
very active tongue no gum cut no zero
Steve's involved at all this is a Steve
free zone but this is like a shoulder
tap surprise surprise attack point out
another very movie like situation like
yeah look is that how your romantic life
plays out as if it isn't film
I wish that'd be great there'd be a lot
more foot pops I would have had at least
one dance around or near a fountain I
have never been picked up on a dock wall
it's raining all of the notebook okay
that is my ultimate goal so it's not
perfect no no one has said if you're a
bird I'm a bird to me and that's really
all I want
speaking from experience it's not all
it's cracked up to be
and well hey link been there done that
you can say have not been there have not
done that so I cannot say the same thing
I was just gonna be really surprised not
I mean not to and so down man there was
a lot of furious making out I at some
point we left that party I left with her
I wouldn't elaborate the rest of the
story from there from there other people
got to use the fridge down other people
yeah I promptly then ignored her for six
months she tried to ask me out a couple
times and I was just like panic I'm very
good at that I panic and run away from
most situations in my life so I had this
very meaningful first kiss I didn't
panic for six months and ran away six
months later she asked me out to the
ballet
does he swan lake' very dark very dark I
went it was a great time we dated for
three and a half years after that
oh yeah y'all met her okay okay yeah
okay
yes got it yeah we did it for three and
a half years after that well you know
what so that so that was a victory it
was a victim Utley a victory it was
definitely as you can tell in both
situations
I was the much more passive actor in
this of just sort of stuff is happening
to me I guess but yeah it was a great I
mean getting tap in the shoulder and
then having having anyone just be like I
am into you enough to shove you up
against a fridge and furiously make out
with you in the middle of this party
it's a great time there was a lot of
raucous applause from friends around his
whole lot of people suddenly were aware
that both of us were very very gay who
had no idea prior to that no I'll never
look at a fridge the same way but you
know what keep your eggs inside of it or
make out for sharing your story and
especially the vulnerability associated
with it yeah we do appreciate that and
now you can and now I'm getting kicked
off the pot I thought about that was
gonna be a weird day and now you can
because I don't know I'm really bad at
that mom yeah right it's understanding
to get off the phone it's like me trying
to trying to kiss my girlfriend yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna go not kiss people well
I mean oh I'm back over here so I mean
now the time has come for me to tell you
my amber story which now don't try to
top mine just because I told mine first
just because I beat you to the punch
doesn't mean you have to swing harder a
lot of this a lot of these stories have
something in common and that is people
not knowing what to do people are not
doing what they want and I definitely
did not know how to go about any of the
things I'm about to talk about but boy
did I want to lots of at that age and
everybody kind of you were an initiator
in general when it came to relationships
yeah yeah I was very much a respondent
very timid but it's interesting because
especially at that age people are sort
of waking up to their own desires at
different rates some people it is
personality based in some ways but then
there are I just you know I don't
remember when it happened but I was just
like I want to kiss a girl I really
really want to even a sixth grade when I
had the Opera this before I'll know old
ear biscuit how I would think about it
all the time even in like first grade I
was already thinking about it how and
how I wanted to make it happen but had
no opportunity then I had that
opportunity with Leslie in sixth grade
just couldn't close the deal cuz I was
just so nervous
sure what by 8th grade because I knew
that like everybody everybody else had
done it yeah I mean you you had kissed
you had kissed amber the previous year
and I don't remember how that
relationship started but it was
definitely one of the classic friend
comes up to you and says oh no well I
always initiated I went to the friend I
think I actually went to Leslie and said
I like amber does never like me about it
being bada-boom and then we were going
and then one of the things that we all
did was we would go to go hang out on
Campbell University's campus and we
would hang out in that restaurant shells
place yeah that was underneath D rich
auditorium which was named after a
student who had been like killed on
campus or something and it was like a
little little restaurant
you mean Michele shells place yeah I
don't know the details I don't it
doesn't exist anymore I don't think it's
in it's in it's it's on campus anymore
but we would go hanging there was no
college to do this but a bunch of middle
schoolers would go hang out there and I
remember going to campus that night
knowing that I was going to kiss amber I
was like this is my chance there's no
parents around and I believe Michael GB
was there probably with Anna at the time
you were not there at the time but there
was a couple other couples you know but
it wasn't like a makeout party situation
it was more like one at a time these
couples were going to leave and go
somewhere else on to campus kiss and
then come back mm-hmm I had on my blue
Nike sweatshirt which I actually took my
school picture in that year it was
special yeah and you wore it on all
special occasions tonight it was gonna
be my favorite article of clothing
anytime you're gonna your premeditating
anything awesome you're gonna wear that
shirt yeah and of course as selfish as I
was and am i don't remember what amber
had on but I had on that blue Nike
sweatshirt you premeditated to be
mythical and I said I'm going to walk
her to the fountain by the way let's do
a t-shirt called premeditate mythicality
it's not that catchy but I mean maybe
you'd okay lots of syllables I'm gonna
walk to the fountain it was nighttime
there's a nice fountain out there that
part of the campus and it is a nice
fountain and I'm like I'm gonna sit down
in again just a just a fountain it's
kind of like a bench amber makes it
makes you feel like this is gonna be
okay because you already knew that she
had kissed
guys and I never kissed anybody but I
just knew that like it wasn't gonna be
this weird thing for her I knew that she
understood what was happening and so
that whole weirdness was taken out of
this out of the fact and she knew when
we got up and walked to the fountain
that that was exactly what was gonna be
happening mm-hmm and the only thing I
was hat was thinking was what Michael
Juby had told me which was you gotta
count he got a count he was a proponent
of the time II of the kid and he's not
even an accountant now he's a lawyer so
but I guess there is a lot of math
involved a lot of counting involved in
that but he was like you gotta count and
so I was thinking I gotta count for
Michael I got a I got a report to
Michael I gotta tell him that means like
well he was in the shells place wait
yeah he was waiting for me to come back
and just flash a number at him you know
and I knew that if I wanted to go back
and and it needed to be something I
could just communicate with my hands I
had to be under ten seconds well I got
in first I didn't want to be in a
situation where I'm like going like 20
hand Morse code I gotta go sub ten
seconds so I can communicate it
so we sit out there for a second I put
my arm around her and I just looked at
her and she looked at me and she had the
I know what's about to happen and I'm
totally into it look on her face which
just made it very easy and and I leaned
in and I gotta say I went in with an
open mouth now not like a I think you I
think your mind is what's supposed to be
open and your mouth is supposed to start
shut and I went in with an open mouth
and there was an exchange there was a
tongue exchange because she was ready
for that I was ready for that I knew
that that was gonna happen you'd heard
many reports of my success yeah and we
kind of gotten it we got into a little
rhythm and then I couple of seconds then
I was like oh shoot I gotta be counting
oh then you had to estimate I had
estimate that had been going for three
seconds and then I was like and that's
what you're gonna come back to to argue
that you still went as long as I did six
seven and then I was out sevens a
complete numbers to prime numbers the
perfect number
and gotta keep it on you gotta keep it
in single digits and so and then and
then you didn't say anything afterward
cuz you don't there's nothing to be said
you just kind of yeah yeah I actually
forgot an important detail and I've told
this story before at some place so I
probably have told that detail but I
actually did what I think is is the
right thing to do I said even though I
knew she was totally okay with it I was
like can I kiss you
that is great I did I mean seriously I
think that is and she was like that is
great and so yeah I first of all the
communication aspect of it is really
important right absolutely
informed consent goes it applies every
way but just the in every direction the
briefing you know the pre-briefing the
post briefing the awkwardness will kind
of go away if you just if you talk about
it a little bit mm-hmm
but it was great he was good we ended up
basically dating that entire
eighth-grade year didn't was Michael
pleased I came back inside gave him the
flashed into seven he gave me the
thumbs-up and you know and then like
many times later we would mean me and
you actually sat and watched Michael
kiss other other people at church
lock-ins remember that yeah I was not
about to make out at a church lock-in
Michael went for so long that accounting
just was it just didn't matter anymore
right it was like an aerobic exercise
it's like yeah what are you going for 20
minutes yeah right it was definitely a
minute situation it was no longer a
second situation so well beyond raw math
but yeah it was uh so but like I said it
was something that I was I mean I mean
we you know we talked about this with
with fact that our kids are in this age
group now yeah they're like they're
right in a sweet spot where when we were
discovering all that and now they're
that age and I haven't told that story I
mean we've talked we've talked about a
lot of things and sort of like general
you know trying to be is educational as
possible and and give the best possible
advice but I have it but I haven't
haven't told lots of personal stories
mostly just and I give it in too many
ideas
I'm currently figuring this out as well
right and so I'd rather not verbally
process but yeah we well you know maybe
next time but yeah I'll say that yeah
we're we're we're figuring this stuff
out I want to keep it about us I'm gonna
respect my the privacy of my oh I'm not
going to tell any stories or mention any
names but yes thank you to all you
mythical beasts who shared your stories
thank you to Ellie and Becca for sharing
their stories yeah thank you thank for
sharing your story you're welcome hmm
thank you for your story - all right
guys we'll talk at you again next week
can we count on you mm-hmm I knew we
could
[Music]